[Music]
thank you I would thank the organizers
for inviting me except I'm one of them
so we could dispense with that this talk
is gonna be a little bit unusual for me
because I normally like to talk about
the newest things going on in the lab
but I made a decision that some older
stuff we've we've been doing or have
done most of which is published would be
more interesting to this group and that
may not have been the right decision but
that's what I've decided to do and the
idea is to suggest some of our findings
that might be relevant to those of you
interested interested in modeling
circuits particularly in cortex so for
most modeled circuits particularly of
cortex excitatory and inhibitory
synaptic inputs are implied to be
glutamatergic glutamate is the main
excitatory transmitter in these circuits
and GABAergic respectively and each is
generally modelled as if they're
relatively homogeneous and functional
however glutamatergic inputs are not
homogeneous I'm going to emphasize that
and why that could be important and also
GABAergic inputs are not the only source
of inhibition in cortex another circuit
so there may be other inhibitory sources
that might be considered for modeling
circuits money of the ideas I'll be
talking about were formed in
collaboration with Ray Galerie who died
last year over and this collaboration
lasted quite a long time so when i say
we' i generally mean ray and me so for
an outline I'm gonna start by talking
about the basic circuitry of thalamus
because this is where these ideas
germinated I'll then talk about the
division of glutamatergic pathways into
what we're calling drivers and
modulators I'll then talk about some
examples of why this has proven to us at
least to be a useful classification then
I'll talk about some properties of the
glutamatergic modulator pathways they're
topography the the fact that they
activate metabotropic receptors and what
this implies and then if I have time I'm
not
how much I'll have how this that
modulator is controlled the gain of
driver inputs and also the tonic burst
firing modes and thalamus so this is
going to be the outline when I talk
about start with thalamus thalamus is a
paired structure of these red modules
right in the center of your brown of the
brain they're their strategic in the
sense that virtually all information
reaching cortex must pass through these
structures and every quarter core area
as far as I know gets an input from
thalamus we can start off by considering
the circuitry of the lateral geniculate
nucleus II really of retinal input to
cortex this serves as a good model for
thalamus we in addition of the
feed-forward two middle layers of cortex
was showing this as layer four there's a
feedback from layer six we call this a
feedback because this feedback
innervates the same relay cells that
innervate that column of cortex and
notice both of these pathways use
glutamate is the neurotransmitter of the
glutamatergic to complete the circuit
there's local GABAergic inputs from
inter neurons and cells of the reticular
thalamic reticular nucleus that provided
inhibition of these relay cells and
finally there's a sending inputs from
various brain stem cell groups call
nerds ignore adrenergic and so on that
provide classic modular tori control of
the circuit now this is a pretty good
model for most of that limits the main
difference between the LGN and any other
thymic relay across species and across
nuclei is the input to be relayed is
different so they're non retinal inputs
are largely conserved there are
differences I'm gonna ignore those
differences for the purposes of this
talk and keep it simple so if this were
the somatosensory relay this would be
the medial lemniscus and so on if you
can identify this input to be relayed
you know a lot about the main function
of a thalamic relay I'm gonna point out
again that there are two glutamatergic
inputs to these relay cells and we've
known for decades that they must have
very different functions if we want to
ask the question
which of these inputs is carrying the
information to be relayed by the LGN we
can gain insight into that question the
answer to that question by noting the
receptive field properties because how a
visual neuron responds to visual stimuli
tells you a lot about the kind of
information it can pass on to its
postsynaptic targets now the receptive
fields of the retinal inputs have the
classic center-surround organization and
they are monarchy driven which means
only stimulation of the eye from which
the ganglion cell sends its axon will
activate this this axon receptive fields
of layer 6 cells are much more
complicated they tend to be binocularly
driven they show a lot of specificity
for things like orientation and
direction also spatial frequency
stereopsis many features that are not
seen in the retinal input so the
question is which of these inputs is
being relayed to cortex which is the
information being relayed and we know
the answer to that by looking at the
receptive field properties of the relay
cell and they pretty much match the
retinal input so we've known for decades
that the rental input provides the
information to be relayed up to cortex
we call this the driver because I when I
used the term driver I'm implying that
that's the main information being
brought into a cell or cell group partly
we call it a driver because it
powerfully drives the postsynaptic cell
with very large epsps so what's going on
here and this is a question that still
have been open but data from our lab and
a number of labs have indicated that's
rarely plot as a modular tori function
much like the classic call nerds ignore
adrenergic and other modular tori
functions and as i'll show it does
affect the relay and gain of driver
inputs so the point here that I'm going
to be building on is that even though
these both use glutamate these two
inputs their function is quite different
and and we followed on to look at some
of these differences and that's what I'm
going to emphasize here I'm going to
take a little detour to tell you about
the techniques we and other labs have
use to study these
these pathways we start with slices from
the mouse brain these slices are about
half a millimeter thick and we start
with the slice first developed by an
Barry Connors lab if you cut the slice
in exactly the right angle and in this
case we're looking at the somatosensory
system you can retain the axons in both
directions between thalamus and cortex
so that you can study these pathways
many other axons are cut and and every
angle of the slice you cut preserve
certain pathways and what others the
nice thing about this is that the
primary somatosensory cortex of the of
the mouse and other rodents has what is
called barrels and lair for that you can
visit you can see in the living slice
each barrel in this case is associated
with the single vibra so and the mice
touch my station pad of the animal snout
and this is nice because you can not
only tell where layer four is but also
where the primary somatosensory cortex
is you know if the example here if we
want to study the phenomena cortical
synapse recording from a cell and
therefore we can activate this pathway
by electrically stimulating but there's
a problem if you just use this approach
and that is that these layer six cells
that I talked about that have axons that
innervate the thalamus have a branch
that goes up to layer four so you can
see that if you stimulate this pathway
with specifying what you're activating
you don't know if you're activating the
green pathway or the red pathway this is
a general problem with these kinds of
experiments and the way we have dealt
with this is to use a technique of
uncaging of glutamate which has now
become a fairly common technique
basically you flood the slice with
glutamate the neurotransmitter but each
glutamate molecule is in a chemical cage
that makes it a nerve
so in this form the Caged glutamate has
no effect on any of these neurons you
can then shine a precisely aimed beam of
late a laser beam and where that beam
strikes these caged molecules it breaks
the cage and allows the glutamate to be
released as if from a synaptic terminal
and the nice thing is that this
glutamate now can only activate profiles
that have glutamate receptors
so we'll activate cell bodies and
dendrites but not axons because these
accidents don't have the glutamate
receptors by using this approach we know
that we're activating this pathway and
so this avoids the what we call the
fiber of passage problem or the anti
drama CAX axon problem if you want to
compliment the uncaging data you can you
use very fine electrical stimulation now
that you know exactly where the cells of
origin are of a pathway but virtually
all the data I'll talk about can rely
simply on the uncaging so you can use
this for instance to record a cell in
cortex activate the thalamic input with
uncaging you can record an thalamus and
look at the cortical amick pathways you
can look at local circuits and cortex
you can look at longer circuits between
cortical areas in this approach so it's
a very flexible approach to study
circuitry in these slices
you know another bits light detour is to
talk about the postsynaptic receptors on
cells mostly on dendrites that are going
to be responsive to glutamate released
by presynaptic terminal they come in two
main flavors ionotropic receptors which
include ampa and nmda are protein
molecules that live in the membrane of
the cell this is outside this is inside
and when they come into contact with a
neurotransmitter glutamate in this case
there's a conformational change that
opens up an ion channel so the ion
channel is part of the complex and these
ion channels usually sodium they can
also be in some cases calcium this
allows a positive ion to flow into the
cell which would depolarize the inside
of the cell and produce the epsp and
it's a fairly fast process metabotropic
receptors for glutamate coming to may
come in actually eight types but we're
going to talk about two types here one
and two and these are more complicated
events so you have a complex protein as
the receptor that has as part of it a
g-protein now when the transmitter it
strikes the receptor the g-protein is
carried away it swims to the membrane
and comes in contact with
another protein complex this is called
the effector protein and this leads to a
whole cascade of second messenger
effects and these second these
biochemical reactions can have many
effects on the cell including changing
expression expression that could have
many many things but one thing that
we've concentrated on in many labs have
as the effect on ion channels
particularly potassium channels and in
this case what this effect is of this
second messenger properties is to close
potassium channels it prevents a
positive ion from leaving the cell and
this leads to an epsp and notice how
prolonged this is at last for hundreds
of milliseconds or in some cases several
seconds and this depolarization lasts
long after the initial event of the
transmitter binding to the receptor this
is what you get with the first type of
metabotropic receptor the second type
does the opposite instead of closing
potassium channels it opens them allows
potassium to leave the cell and this
leads to a long i PS P so in this case
we can look we can see that glutamate
attached to the correct receptor can
actually inhibit cells and for a very
long time another important difference
has to do with the location of these
receptors the inotropic receptors tend
to live right at the synapse whereas the
metabotropic receptors seem to be
further away usually seen as being
forming an annulus around the the
synapse and one thing this means or this
is the explanation for that ionotropic
receptors respond even a single action
potentials so the transmitter is
released and it'll affect these
receptors but to activate so any
frequency of firing here can can get you
an ample response but in order to
activate metabotropic receptors
typically you have to have firing and
the axon of greater than about 10 Hertz
this of this can vary of course in order
to release enough transmitter to reach
the more distant receptors what this
means is that this axon if it's not
firing very much
will only activate ionotropic receptors
but as it becomes more interested in
life it'll start bringing in
metabotropic component the higher our
fire is the board of the metabotropic
component plays a role in the responses
to show how this all works this is a
slice preparation it turns out from the
cat we're recording from a relay cell in
the cap lateral geniculate nucleus and
what I'm going to show you here is has
been demonstrated in rodents and
primates as well if you activate the
modulator input from layer 6 you see
this pattern of activation the PSP's is
you know it gets get larger as as the
Train of stimulation goes on this is
called a facilitating pattern and it's
correlated with a very low probability
of release of the at the terminal of
transmitter each action potential has a
low probability of releasing transmitter
you also note that as you increase the
power or the electricity here you
increase the size of the PSP's and this
suggests that is the current spreads
you're bringing in more and more axons
and this is consistent with more cannot
of convergence in this input as long as
the stimulation is at low frequencies
about 10 Hertz or so you can knock it
out completely by using amp and NMDA
receptors and what these receptors are
still in place you can demonstrate the
metabotropic component of this pathway
by a burst of about 10 shocks at 5200
Hertz so it's it's fast enough to reduce
enough transmitter and you get this very
long slow epsp you notice the time
course here and if we now add to this of
a specific metabotropic glutamate one
blocker you knock that out so this is
the metabotropic component from this
pathway we can then from the same cell
look at the driver input and we see
everything is different
much larger epsps activated at an
all-or-none manner as if there's very
little convergence in this pathway and
they depress they get smaller instead of
larger as you go through
trained and this is a correlative to
very high probability of release at this
at this synapse which is these are
properties you want you'd want in a
driver and there's no metabotropic
component only ionotropic components
okay so to summarize these differences
I'll use a flaw McCree lay cell to start
the driver inputs there's some
anatomical correlates here as well
innovate proximal dendrites and complex
adaptive zones known as glomeruli they
activate only inotropic receptors and
I've already talked about the activation
profile modulators have more convergence
and they innervate distal dendrites they
activate the taboo topic as well as
inotropic receptors again the activation
profile I've gone over there's also
other anatomical differences the drivers
tend to arrive over very thick axons
with a small butt but at large terminals
and very dense arbors whereas the
modulars have very thin axons strictly
small terminals and very sparse are
verts so all these differences that we
see in thalamus apply pretty much in
cortex as well though the data and
cortex aren't quite as good with the
exception of the glomerulus the
glomerulus is of lamech feature it's not
found in cortex but numbers are also
important here because if you consider
all these synapses on the relay cell the
driver inputs represent less than 5%
these glutamatergic inputs represented
now order of magnitude more synapses
which is surprising if we're calling the
driver and put the important one for
information transfer the rest of the
inputs come from GABAergic and classical
modulatory inputs but it's interesting
that these numbers are also seen at the
first stage of processing and in cortex
so phenom according all inputs to layer
four cells which are the drivers
represent about five to six percent of
the synapses and the modulator inputs
that have been identified on these layer
four cells represent about 40 to 50
percent so all these features seem to
apply to cortex as well including the
majority of
Clement urging inputs being modulator
zall though the numbers in in cortex are
much more limited but the examples that
we're limited this is a general pattern
of some of the differences we can we've
identified these two kinds of inputs and
brows brain slices onto another a number
of examples onto thalamic cells
activating different kinds of inputs to
them I'm not going to go through this in
detail and on to cortical cells I'm just
making the point that what I'm going to
show you in the next few slides is based
on examples from a number of different
thematic and cortical cells and
activating different kinds of it we're
going to make inputs to them so if we
look at a table of differences there are
there are 10 or 12 of these parameters
that we've identified that we believe
largely to be independent of one another
we wanted to show how these distribute
in scatter plots and we picked three of
them to quantify I think any three would
give us the same picture the three were
we've chosen or these three here the
details of which aren't important but
when we apply these we get scatter plots
that look like this each point here
represents a single cell from from which
we've identified glutamatergic input as
driver or modulator onto the cell and
the color code tells you whether the
cell is in thalamus or in cortex and
there are a couple of points to make
from this the difference between drivers
or modulator x' is quite robust and I
hope you're convinced by this alone that
the classification does tell us that
there are different kinds of
glutamatergic input second point is we
only see two frankly when we got into
the more complicated circuitry of cortex
we expected to find more classes so far
we haven't maybe as people explore other
areas of cortex or other parts of the
brain there will be other kinds of
glutamatergic synapse identified the
third point is that the modulator
properties on two thalamic and Wieland
cortical cells are pretty much similar
as are the driver properties as if we
have two basic kinds of glutamatergic
synapse that operate in thalamus and
cortex the hypothesis is that drivers
are carrying the main information and
Marja leaders affect how the drive
puts her process this hypothesis pretty
strongly supported we believe in the
lamech circuits in cortex I think the
the jury's still out we need more
evidence for cortical circuitry it is
more complicated but the evidence that
does exist is consistent with this
hypothesis but it's far from proving it
I'm going to provide a couple of
examples of of how using this
classification changes that the the
common or textbook view of the
functional organization of circuits I'm
gonna start by throwing out something
that ray Guillory and I have worked on
to show how cortical areas are connected
because this will be important for a
couple of the examples I'll be showing
if this is the visual system this is
primary cortex and we can move up the
hierarchy we've known for a long time
that these areas are connected directly
with each other but what ran out of the
emphasize is that there's a parallel
pathway to connect these areas through
thalamus in this case pulvinar and it
does appear to be the case so far that
when cortical areas have a direct
connection there's what we call a trans
lamech one that also goes through the
thalamus so there's something
interesting here all cortical relays get
a feedback from layer 6 that is
glutamatergic and modular Tory but these
pulvinar cells in addition get a
cortical input from layer 5 that is
feed-forward and Driver because these
the synapse here has exactly the same
properties as the retinal input to the
lateral geniculate nucleus this duality
we called the LGN an exemplar of a
first-order relay because it's a relay
of first relay of a particular kind of
information of cortex and pulvinar
higher-order relay because it's relaying
information already in cortex between
cortical areas if you're asking about
bandwidth the pulvinar is about 30 to 50
times larger in volume than the LGN so
there's a lot of bandwidth for this to
go up the hierarchy this duality applies
not just to the visual system but the
somatosensory system has VP as the
first-order relay the posterior meter
group is higher order the ventral part
of the medial geniculate nucleus is
first-order for for auditory processing
the doors
division higher order and so on at the
medial dorsal nucleus which is the
second largest relay and thalamus we see
is mostly if not completely higher-order
connecting areas of prefrontal cortex so
we believe that most of the limits by
volume provide provides us kind of
higher-order function okay with that in
mind I want to consider textbook views
of how sensory information reaches
primary and higher areas of cortex so
and the idea is that there are parallel
routes of information from their
periphery so for the visual system the
idea is that one pathway goes through
the LGN two primary cortex but there's a
second pathway in parallel that goes for
the superior colliculus and pulvinar two
cortex and we see the same in the
auditory system two parts of the
inferior colliculus the core in shell
region have these parallel inputs
through what we're calling first and
higher-order relays and for the
somatosensory system we get parallel
processing from the principal nucleus of
the fifth of and the spinal nucleus of
the fifth nerve this would seem to be
somewhat at odds with what when telling
you that these higher-order relays are
not used for a parallel subcortical
input to go to cortex but rather using
these transatlantic cortical cortical
pathways so to address this we start
with the auditory system we used a slice
preparation that preserved the
connectivity between the inferior
colliculus and the medial geniculate we
can record from a cell there do our
uncaging over the in a grid over the
colliculus find the hotspot where the
cells that provide excited to report
these are an inward currents here's a
cell recorded from then we could test
these synapses for whether their driver
or modulator for the meniscal pathway
which is the core of the colliculus to
the ventral part of the medial genican
every single cell showed a driver
pattern depressing synapse and no sign
of the metabotropic receptor for the Ron
Illumina sickle pathway from the shell
of the colliculus to the dorsal division
we found the opposite every cell here
and it's quite a dramatic there
once showed facilitating synapse and a
type-1 metabotropic receptor component
and so we suggest that this textbook
view of what's going on here is not
correct instead what's going on is that
this so-called parallel pathway is
really providing modular Tori actions on
the transatlantic pathway and this is
again if you if you follow the logic
here using the driver modulator
distinction does change the way you look
at the functional organization in the
circuit we can take this to other
examples here we so for the auditory
system we suggest this is what's going
on and we see a very similar thing for
paper we just published and the
somatosensory systems a little bit more
complicated but it's pretty much the
same we don't know yet for the visual
system this is on our list to test one
final example has to do with the basal
ganglia I believe there's some interest
in basal ganglia here when I look at
textbook views they show the basal
ganglia is part of an information loop
that you follow the information from
cortex through the basal ganglia to
thalamus and back up to cortex and we
think there's a problem with this that
has to do with the nature of the basal
ganglia input to thalamus so if we look
at the motor thalamus which is mostly
va/vl a complex of ventral anterior and
ventral lateral nuclei we see two inputs
that are relevant when from the deep
nuclei of the cerebellum and the other
from the basal ganglia the problem is
the basal ganglion put a strictly
Gaborik and we'd have argued that every
ethnic nucleus has a driver input that
represents the information to be relayed
and that that driver input is
glutamatergic which suggests that this
is not an information route if that's
correct and we can parse this because
this va/vl complex is really a mosaic
and what's interesting is that data in
the in the rat and in the monkey has
shown that the cerebellar input and the
basal ganglion put in void each other
they each innervate different
territories of this mosaic
furthermore there is a layer 5 input to
the structure and it seems to target
strictly the region of va/vl that is
innervated by the basal ganglion avoids
a cerebellar input so it looks to us and
what we're suggesting is the with the
syrup with the basal ganglia is doing
just like the previous examples of the
sensory pathways is it's modulating
affecting the gate because it's
GABAergic of the transonic pathway and
again that's a somewhat different view
of what how the basal ganglia relates to
cortex that it's not providing basic
information be relayed but is doing
something else here so an example could
be seen as follows I mentioned you
imagine you have a cortical area that
has direct connections and transonic
ones to a number of other motor cortical
areas the base of ganglia input is
active here and here that leaves only
these two pathways these two connections
with other cortical areas is having both
pathways intact and the pattern can
change depending on which nuclei are
getting active inputs from the basal
ganglia at that time this could be seen
as a very dynamic process now what this
actually means I could only speculate
but one possibility is that dynamic
input to a cortical area is necessary
not necessarily if is sufficient but
necessary for the columns in that
quarter corner to function properly and
if I were talking about new data from
our lab I'd provide some data to support
that and that means that these areas
that aren't getting it slam again put
anymore
are not functioning property properly
and that means that only these areas are
connected functionally with the primary
area here it may also be that there's
some coincidence detection going on
that's very important for the
functioning of these areas but in any
case this is one idea of what the basal
ganglia is actually doing which I think
comes from this brought primarily from
the driver modulator distinction and
it's still not seen in textbook versions
of this if you know I'm going to talk
about some properties of these
glutamatergic modulators
and try to finish up quickly you might
ask
since the thalamus gets all these
classic modulators why is there a
glutamatergic modulator added one and we
suggest that has to do with typography
the cholinergic NORAD generic and so on
modular Tory inputs are very diffusely
organized for things like focal
attention adaptation anything where you
just want one or two cortical areas to
be affected
you need topographic modulation because
if you're dependent on own cholinergic
for instance modulation you modulate the
entire cortex the same way when you only
want certain small areas to be affected
so you need to have topographic
modulation and the glutamatergic inputs
are the only ones we know of that can do
that so if you look at all the classic
ones this is from a textbook you see
that they're very diffusely organized
with very little typography but only the
glutamatergic ones provide the
modulation that is highly topographic
and so we think it's necessary for for
many of the functions I've suggested and
you can imagine many others I have two
more points I'd really like to have a
time to go over but I'll start with what
happens when these metabotropic
glutamate receptors are activated
there's an example again of a driver
input
it's the phlegm of cortical input the
layer for depressing synapse no
metabotropic component there's a
modulator layer six cortical input two
islamic relay cell i've already gone
over this facilitating synapse and a
large depolarizing metabotropic response
that can be blocked by a type one
blocker but we have another example here
and this is the layer six to layer four
modulation here you get the strong ipsp
the lasts for a long time so you can get
both excitation and inhibition depending
on the receptor and this is blocked by
type two blocker so to show this the
importance of the staining this is a
monocyte achill staining for this type
two
a receptor and you can see it's in all
these three sensory areas it's very
densely found particularly in layers
four and six but in other layers as well
so from this and from our recordings I
would argue that the type 2 min
temperature of a response that provides
inhibition it's pretty widely
distributed in cortex and it certainly
shouldn't be ignored so again if we
focus on this branch of the layer 6 cell
that innervates layer 4 we can study
that by uncaging record from a layer 4
cell on cage and you see that there's a
region here that provides some inward
currents so this is the connection this
is just false color view of the hotspot
here that provides input to therefore if
we activate if we do uncaging at a high
rate you see the on a tropic response
here but we can ignore that this is the
metabotropic component and we know that
because if we put the Angora one block
and we reduce that if we do a
subtraction you can see what the
metabotropic component is and it's
fairly substantial this is another
example where we're recording from layer
4 cell the hot spot is here under the
triangle but here we get a different
response here's our inhibitory
metabotropic component if we see it when
we wash it away
and this is due to a type 2 metabotropic
receptor we also see this in cortical
cortical connections here we see a
driver input from v1 to v2 layer 4 -
therefore here we see a modulator from
layer 2 3 - layer 2 3 that has a type 1
metabotropic response but here's one
familiar 6 - layer 5 a that is type 2 so
we see these inhibitory responses in a
variety of different cortical cortical
circuits the final main point I want to
make and I think I can quit after this
is using these metabotropic receptors
and the modular Tory pathways to change
the gain of driver inputs
so in this experiment we're recording
from a cell and layer 2 3 and the
uncaging shows hotspot and layer 4 just
below it as well as smaller hotspot on
to each side and it's shown here you can
see the lateral hotspots and the larger
one just below it so you can record from
the cell and activate these two inputs
and see how they interact because as
we'll see the layer 4 input is a driver
a depressing synapse no metabotropic
component whereas the the layer 2
lateral input is a modulator
facilitating synapse and a large type 2
metabotropic component what happens when
we activate the Matt Abbott from the
trumpet component to see what effect
that has on the driver input from layer
4 delay or 2/3 that's we're gonna look
at here again a recording here when we
just stimulate layer 4 we get this
pattern the depressing pattern but when
we do the stimulation after activating
the the modulator input and remember the
action can last for hundreds of
milliseconds to several seconds after
you stop the stimulation the EPS C's
that are evoked seems smaller than here
but if we do this with a metabotropic
blocker the same experiment we don't see
any effect on these epsps and C's you to
see if we take them apart this is the
effect of a large reduction of ESP epsps
when we activate this modulator pathway
but when we activate it with the type 2
metabotropic receptor blocked we don't
have any effect
so to summarize we've seen this in the
layer 4 to layer 2 3 in both visual and
auditory cortex there's a reduction in
this synapse when you activate the
pathway from v1 to v2 the bad I'm sorry
the feedback from higher auditory or
visual or areas 2 primary in layer 4 the
input from LGN by this pathway is
knocked down
we the layer 6 input LGN when this
modulate later pathways as seen you can
knock down the rattle input but what's
interesting if we go back to this and we
look at the margin Victorian put alone
from layer
six one of these cells there is no
effect on activating the modern
modulator pathway now I'd like many more
examples to see if there's a real
pattern here what we can say is in many
cases driver inputs have their synaptic
strengths affected by the modulator
inputs to the same cell we haven't found
yet an example where that's true for
modulator modulator inputs but again
this is early stages and we needed a lot
more examples this last point I'm just
going to go over very quickly and just
make a point I'm not going to go through
the actual data this is for those of you
who really care about economic relay
cells in the fact that they can be
activated in either burst or tonic
manner and these response modes are very
important to the nature of the relayed
to cortex and autonomic relays I'll show
this these response modes are called are
controlled by voltage-gated conductances
and we and others have shown that those
voltage-gated conductances are
controlled very effectively by the layer
six modular Tory feedback and and if you
by activating the layer six feedback you
can very clearly and precisely control
which response modes these relay cells
will be firing in I'm happy to talk
about that in detail a buddy
offline I don't have time to go over it
here okay so to summarize the driver
modulator classification leads to a very
different way of looking at through the
metallurgic circuit properties and
information transfer modulators appear
dominant and climbing and cortical
circuitry so if you just do a
connectomics approach and just count up
all the synapses you haven't assumed
that the pathway with the largest number
of synapses is the important one
I hope you realize that that could be
very misleading glutamatergic modulator
provide topographic modulation which we
think is a very important feature of
them and the main thing that
distinguishes them from the classic
modulators ignores our ubiquitous and
cortical anomic circuitry if you need a
prolonged process that they that takes
up to several seconds think of
metabotropic glutamate
because activation of em Wars can
produce excitation or inhibition
depending on the receptors involved and
the inhibition could be quite profound
and long-lasting activation of em
glowers can also affect the gain of
driver inputs at least in some cases and
as I've said very quickly it also
controls the burst firing mode and
thalamus and I leave this with the
question how important is it to
incorporate these concepts of modulator
Zand drivers in modular what was the
cortical circuitry I don't know the
answer to that it may be that this isn't
terribly important yet with awhile we
are able to capture the functional
properties of cortical circuitry and
circuitry in other parts of the brain
but the purpose of this talk was to
alert people to the importance of this
in getting a detailed understanding of
how these circuits operate thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
great question how useful is this
outside thalamus and cortex
I can only say it's a great question I
think we need to know the answer to that
and I think that let me put this in in
some context when when you go in to
study a new structure like the retina or
cortex one of the first things you will
need to do is classify the different
elements there so to understand retina
for instance you need first to know that
there are rods and cones and ganglion
cells which is maybe equivalent the
level I'm talking about the different
transmitter systems but now we know we
have many different classes of ganglion
cells and amacrine cells in retina and
that's analogous to many different
classes within transmitter systems
talking about this for glutamate I think
the classification of
circuits based on transmitter systems
hasn't really been done very
systematically the idea of cholinergic
pathways are all the same and so and I
think that question has to be there has
to be a proper classification to see how
many types of cholinergic input there
are and this could apply as you suggest
throughout the the nervous system
peripheral as well as central
to suggest there's some correlation
between my hand poses noting which
operators have tourettes but on the
other hand whether it's in our
facilitator and suppression applies just
to the inotropic responses not to the
metabotropic so i don't see any any
problem that they're independent but the
facilitation and depression with the
facilitation and depression is defined
strictly on the basis of the responses
of the inotropic receptors so the fact
that a cell can be either it turns out
that the cells that shows suppression
facilitation of the ones that have been
temperature receptors that's an
empirical observation I don't
particularly
that's right so we're looking at a
specific pathway that shows only one or
the other
no I don't know if this was your
question but what why don't we see more
evidence of activating pathways that
show both and so you can imagine
activating a pathway that has both
drivers and modulators as an example
maybe I should have mentioned this but
one surprise to us is that we just don't
see that very often when we do it's very
obvious and to make sure that we have
artificially or not artificially we
activated known pathways to a cell that
are both one pathway is driver on the
other pathways modulator just to see
what that would look like and it's very
easy to see that so when we activate
these pathways the way we've done we see
almost no examples ever been a few but
almost no examples of mixture between
drivers and modulators that was a
surprise to us I'm not sure what to make
of that but they do seem to be
separately organized in terms of where
the inputs are coming from
so do you think that could also be
driver on the donators there and I'm
suing the LMS you have lots of
interneurons and do they have different
targets like so much right so GABAergic
inputs we are asserting this could be
challenge this is pure speculation
cannot be drivers that drivers have to
be by our by our claim glutamatergic a
subset of these glutamatergic inputs one
reason is that if you look if you try to
model the cut the amount of information
you can get across an inhibitory synapse
it's much lower than excitatory synapses
it has to do with the fact that well we
can we can talk about that offline this
has been modeled so GABAergic synapses
turns out are very inefficient in
getting information across a synapse
unless the postsynaptic cell is firing
at very high rates more than about 200
Hertz in our modeling other questions
about determination on postsynaptic
cells context is very complicated some
some go for the initial segment of the
axon I mean they're all so different the
different gabbard's excels and cortex
are very different innovation patterns
on the postsynaptic cells and thalamus
we see that too on the relay cells there
are two main GABAergic inputs the local
inter neurons innervate proximal
dendrites the TRN cells innovate distal
dendrites and there's no overlap and
their territories they can we can
speculate about what that might mean but
in cortex as you know it's even more
complicated than that but very specific
targets for the different classes of
GABAergic so and we see that in Thomas
also
the facilitation auric depression is
thought to be a property of the
probability of release of transmitter
and that in turn seems related very
closely to the size of the calcium
conductance that is generated in the
presynaptic terminal through the
invading active potential whether it's
active or not and this has been modeled
quite nicely and things that allow you
to change the the calcium conductance by
change in the how much calcium there is
an extracellular fluid all support that
idea so to step back if the calcium
conductance in the terminal is
relatively small you get less
probability of transmitter release and
that will lead to facilitation if it's
big you get the opposite so it seems to
be best explained strictly on
presynaptic terms about how much
transmitter is being released
you're asking about modulated versus
drivers not sure what you mean by
bandwidth and drivers so if you apply
information theory for that I think what
you'd need to do would be able to record
pre and postsynaptic lis simultaneously
that's been done for driver inputs
retina 2 geniculate and in some cases
thalamus 2 layer foreign cortex I don't
know if anybody that successfully done
this with modulators and here's the
problem let's take the LGN as an example
the LGN gets input from 1 to 3 retinal
ganglion cells so it's possible to do
the paired recording and see a big
effect we estimate that the layer 6
input to the same cells the module
eaters have at least a hundred maybe
several hundred converging axons e4 each
of which produces only about ten
synapses if you did a paired recording
there you'd have such a weak response
that it would be very difficult to see
people have tried and they and they
report at best some very weak responses
that that are so hard that people have
pretty much given up trying to do that
experiment so I don't know if anybody's
applied information theory for the
driver synapses but the modulator ZnO I
don't know of anybody that's done that I
just think it hasn't been done
technically just too difficult
so can you comment about TRN and like is
today is six synapses here and that's
also modulator
right so TR n its input from axons that
go through the TR n they include the
layer six cells that come down to
innervate the thalamus and the thalamic
relay cells that go up to cortex both
provide branches if you're asking which
of those is driver that's not been
clearly that's a good question that
should be addressed
it hasn't been clearly addressed yet the
best guess based on weak and direct
evidence is that the relay cell is
providing the driver input and the
cortical the modular and they'd spaced
strictly on the size of the synapses
that are formed and that's only one of
these parameters and I'm not sure how
reliable that is in this case so that's
really still an open question I think
picture let's say I can call it that
paradigm you basically have your work
paradigm you have a a certain with
information flowing in it which has
modulators and drivers which you can
then block and therefore identify
drivers and versus modulators what and
and basically the whole discussion goes
in that and it's it's information flow
discussion I'm wondering just kind of
make the discussion bigger he can if one
said okay I'm not allowed to talk about
well basically the circuit lines that
you're drawing are huge wires from area
to area but of course if we look at
professor boxes picture or something we
would say instead those interactions are
driving the search in a very complicated
space statistically in a different play
or one could also say you know your work
modifying parameters that meet an
attractor Network goes somewhere else
and so the only the only thing I'm
throwing out is we wonder discussion is
whether that circuit model assuming
information flow is really going to work
according to the theorists so in other
words if you have if you have a feeding
so if you have feedback if you have
feedback do you have can you use
information flow as your basic concept
if you if you're showing your emphasis
is feedback there's a strong feedback
I'm not sure I'm not sure I'm not trying
to follow the reasoning there if you
believe in a hierarchy of cortical areas
isn't the information going let's say
from v1 to v2 information if you ever if
you have a highly expand I don't know if
you can use the information I'm out of
my depth pairs
I don't have any insight there
[Applause]